imagine paying people
no-strings-attached cash whether they
have a job or not there's the need for a
new kind of safety net
it's a utopian idea that something could
be the solution to a potentially jobless
dystopian future this wave of automation
is coming and it hasn't crashed over
Society yet that's going to in
California too experiments are being
planned that could point to a radically
different future of work
[Music]
Stockton California just five years ago
the city was declared bankrupt today
unemployment is almost double the
national average and many people live
paycheck to paycheck
but the city's mayor Michael Tubbs has a
plan to combat an increasingly unequal
and insecure jobs market
[Music]
starting this year a hundred residents
will receive a guaranteed income of five
hundred dollars per month whether they
work or not
the mayor's plan is inspired by the
radical idea of a universal basic income
or ubi an unconditional cash payment for
all citizens the experiment will measure
the impact of these payments on the
recipients lives
mayor Tubbs believes it could be the key
to helping the working poor those who
have jobs but find it hard to make ends
meet the universal basic income works
out in Stockton you will see the poverty
levels decrease I do think there'll be
more discussions about things like the
social safety net and basic income for
sure the truth is one in two of every
American can afford one $500 emergency
which means that the majority of the
country is not doing that well
I'm the first to say that for three
years worth of work I ended up with
nearly half a billion dollars that is
not how the economy is supposed to work
Chris Hughes is one of the people paying
for Mayer tubbses experiment he made his
money as a co-founder of Facebook but
the online revolution he's profited from
could mean rising insecurity for the
workers of tomorrow now he spends his
time looking for new ways to deliver a
fairer society we're seeing massive
growth in the number of part-time jobs
contingent workers in the gig economy
and with that instability comes a need
for a new kind of safety net a $500 a
month in the background every single
month for people who need it so that in
the great months you know that you're
gonna be good and in the months when
work isn't quite as stable you know
you're at least halfway to making rent
skeptics argue no-strings-attached
handouts could discourage people from
working but Chris Hughes says research
to date suggests that top-ups have
beneficial effects when people get
modest amounts of cash they use it to
improve their lives and the lives of
their family they invest it in
themselves most importantly people don't
drop out of work on mass our generation
is gonna have to deal with tens of
millions of jobs replaced by automation
like self-driving cars and trucks
Silicon Valley seems a wash with
billionaires eager to allay fears about
an uncertain future of work fears stoked
by the very innovations that have made
them their billions universal basic
income is one of these ideas that's been
talked about and debated a lot so we
thought it'd be really good given what
we think is going to happen in the world
if we could get some data Sam Altman is
president of a Silicon Valley school for
startups and he is about to launch the
most rigorous experiment in basic income
ever carried out in America 3,000 people
will receive either 50 or $1,000 with no
strings attached every month for the
next few years
most economists argue a basic income
would be just too expensive for
governments to provide today but Sam
Altman claims the rise of the robots
could ultimately have an answer for that
if the AI comes the good news is the
cost of goods and services come down
dramatically as computers can do them so
inexpensively in a world like that you
know we'd see effective GDP growth in
terms of purchasing power skyrocket in
the world where the AI really does
arrive there will be plenty of money
[Music]
supporters of a basic income even
believe it could change people's
attitudes towards work itself we're
definitely not there we define what we
think of his work but we've had to do
that many times before and one of the
things that we learn in Silicon Valley
is just how much potential some people
have and then if you can unlock that if
you can free them from having to work a
job that they hate just to be able to
survive will create hugely more value
for the world
[Music]
you